[Musique]
oui
salut les terriens salut les terriens
bienvenue dans votre touques du samedi
soir bonsoir
toute l'équipe de salut les terriens
affirme sa plus sincère compassion aux
victimes des massacres de vendredi à
paris mais plutôt qu'une minute de
silence je vous propose d'écouter le
morceau que le groupe eagles of death
metal jouer au bataclan quand la
fusillade a commencé juste pour dire à
ces connards que le rock'n'roll n'est
pas mort
jean
alors
[Applaudissements]
avec nous ce soir
3 terriens de choix dounia bouzar
amusant bonsoir vous êtes anthropologue
directrice du centre de prévention
contre les dérives sectaires liées à
l'islam et votre travail consiste à
expliquer à des jeunes que c'est pas
bien de couper des têtes pour jouer au
football
autres terriens invité ce soir un homme
de conviction il est notamment convaincu
d'avoir tout le temps raison jean luc
mélenchon
autres terrière invité ce soir celui qui
a dit en parlant de moi que j'étais né
dans une bassine de méchanceté le
problème pour lui ce soir c'est que
c'est vrai
guillaume diot
moi
après le zapping du lion nous
accueillerons notre intérieur du samedi
20 heures ce soir alain robert le
spiderman français l'homme qui escalade
des gratte-ciel à manu voilà l'émission
s'appelle salut les terriens et le
groupe le gréement de fortune
[Musique]
et maintenant voici comme villa
la droite d'entrer mais faut pas
déconner non plus ouais c'est pas une
musique à la grande musique d'entrée
classe comme celle-là bon thierry
bonsoir à tous pas de débrief de
l'émission de la semaine dernière parce
qu'il n'y a pas eu démission la semaine
dernière à cause des événements alors
bien entendu on a une grosse pensée pour
toutes les victimes ainsi que pour leurs
familles et leurs proches mais bon comme
faut qu'on continue à vivre je vais
essayer très modestement de faire ce que
je sais mieux apporter des cafés
ce soir à plateau de qualité jean luc
mélenchon alors jean-luc je sais pas
comment faire des blagues sur lui parce
que j'ai peur qu'ils me gueule dessus en
même temps là où j'ai une chance de m'en
sortir sécu pas journaliste vous savez
que dans le petit larousse illustré à
côté du mot colère il ya votre photo
jean-luc
alors pour ceux qui ne connaîtraient pas
jean luc mélenchon il est très très à
gauche voilà jean luc la seule fois de
sa vie où il est passé à droite c'était
au volant d'une voiture en angleterre
[Applaudissements]
mais ce cas là c'est marrant c'est
qu'aujourd'hui un mec qu'on qualifie
d'extrême gauche il ya vingt ans c'était
juste un socialiste en fait ouais
effectivement le problème c'est
qu'aujourd'hui si la gauche ses valses
et macro tout le monde et d'extrême
gauche
guillaume durand guillaume vous êtes à
l'antenne de radio classique la radio
préférée des salles d'attentes de
médecins
alors sur l'antenne vos collègues sont
ppda claire chazal christian morin en
fait c'est une radio sa maison de
retraite de tf1
new york autant pour moi donc là c'est
le cimetière alors
vous avez vous avez votre émission aussi
sur tv5 monde et selon un récent sondage
vous êtes l'animateur préféré des
français à l'étranger qui sont bloqués à
l'hôtel à cause d'une touriste à
[Applaudissements]
dounia bouzar bon soit revenir à
l'ordinaire vous avez un papa
maroco-algérien une maman d'origine
corse et italiennes en fait vous êtes la
tour de babel à vous tout seul c real
jérome à roko italo corse un conseil
vous prenez pas la tête avec dounia
parce que vu ses origines elle doit
avoir un caractère de merde
dounia vous luttez pour que les jeunes
ne deviennent pas des djihadistes alors
un djihadiste qu'est ce que c'est et bah
c'est un peu comme un critique
littéraire à la télé c'est juste un mec
qui lit des livres en diagonale
alors on a découvert qu'il y avait une
grosse filières djihadistes en belgique
ou en décompte thierry même les
kamikazes ils veulent payer moins
d'impôts
ma mission ici mesdames et messieurs
comme toutes les semaines passent et de
poser les questions trop con que thierry
ardisson n'a pas voulu vous posez
guillaume durand il ya peu de temps vous
avez clash et stéphane bern et sa vision
rance de la culture alors le clash berne
durant c'est quoi c'est comme le clash
rohff booba mais par contre avec des
brushings et des vestes en tweed
dounia bouzar dounia vous avez autour de
vous un protocole de sécurité très
strictes par exemple n'avait pas le
droit de vous faire livrer des paquets
mais du coup quand vous commandez
chinois livreur il arrive avec du riz
cantonnais dans les poches
jean luc mélenchon jean luc lors des
dernières élections présidentielles vous
avez terminé derrière marine le pen
c'était quoi le pire c'était là la
défaite ou la vue
bravo c'est une jambe il notre carrière
que l'on retrouve ici la semaine
prochaine et au théâtre apollo voilà
jean luc mélenchon revend soir
merci d'être avec nous ce soir on est
ravi de vous avoir car il ya quelques
temps suit un échange un peu tendu avec
bruce toussaint à matin sur i télé a
déclaré voilà une expérience qui me
décide à réduire encore le nombre de
chaînes où j'accepte de me rendre je
n'aurais pas dû faire cette matinale
j'ai perdu mon temps vous dites que
bruce vous a manqué de respect qu est ce
qu il a fait bon c'est une interview
comme ça arrive à certains moments où on
pose pas des questions mais on fait des
réponses et vous devez réagir au bout
d'un moment il ya la marque et puis
c'était madame le pen ceci madame à elle
cela est est ce que vous pensez que vous
n'avez pas madame le pen non
moi je crois plus à d'autres formes plus
tranquille plus par exemple c'est très
agréable d'aller chez durand le bol
c'est que c'est vraiment très tôt sinon
c'est parfait et un problème de réveil
en fait moi je suis ravi parce que je
fais partie des émissions et acceptant
urd de vous rendre ça peut changer en
fonction des vannes oui en effet je vais
vous faire ce que j'en suis tout à fait
conscient vous savez alors en plus y'a
un truc c'est qu'ici vous savez qu'après
l'émission il ya du champagne et du shit
et mais ni l'un ni l'autre hélas pondre
un bon
bon alors dans la deuxième partie de
l'émission nous parlerons évidemment
longuement de la guerre contre des chefs
mais auparavant je voudrais aborder le
reste de l'actu avec vous faites partie
de la gauche d'opposition
si cette gauche qui pense qu'il est plus
grave de perdre son emploi que sa
chemise
concernant les salariés d'air france qui
est d'arracher ses chemises aux drh vous
avez soumis leurs actions et vous avez
proposé d'aller en prison à leur place
d'une autorité virer quand même mais
c'est très injuste
j'ai trouvé absolument insupportable que
le lendemain signé de larmes que pour
cet homme et sa chemise arrachée et que
l'on oublie 2900 personnes condamnées à
la mort sociale parce que le chômage
aujourd'hui c'est souvent ça et on ne
laisse à toutes ces personnes d'autres
choix que de laisser éclater leur colère
et la souffrance des salariés n'est
jamais à l'ordre du jour vous savez
thierryardisson si vous ouvrez un
journal vous gardez une émission de télé
il ya un goût pour la chose qui choque
qui a un bon donc parmi toutes les
choses choquantes comment se fait-il
qu'ils en est une qui ne soit jamais là
c'est que il meurt plus d'une personne
par jour sur son poste de travail même
le csa était conduit à dire ce qu'on ne
voit jamais à la télévision ce sont les
ouvriers et les employés on ne les voit
jamais
[Applaudissements]
alors
les régionales alors évidemment avec ce
qui s'est passé vendredi on parle plus
des régionales les campagnes sont
arrêtés vous me direz c'est bientôt noël
et les gens savent bien que voter aux
régionales ou écrire une lettre au père
noël c'est à peu près la même chose ce
semblant d'y croire mais on sait que ça
ne servira à rien je ne dirais pas ça
parce que c'est bon alors nous sommes un
peuple libre il ya une élection notre
devoir est d'y partir et de nous y
intéresser je reconnais que la situation
n'est pas fameuse déjà parce que les
gens venaient tout juste d'arriver à
comprendre en 20 ans dans quelles
régions administratives ils vivaient que
françois hollande change une première
fois la carte et puis en cours de route
se dit ah bah tiens je change de
changement et il a créé 13 régions qui
n'existe pas par exemple comme vous
habitez guéret vous devez faire un
programme commun avec biarritz alors est
ce que c'est possible oui mais ça ça
s'appelle la france ne s'appelle pas la
région je posais suspect c'est de
claquer la région c'est pour dire on a
créé des artefacts qui ne correspondent
à aucune structure de l'état et c'est
une élection qui est très nationale et
mes amis sur le terrain s'évertue à
essayer d'expliquer pourquoi il faut
être vigilant quand même sur ce que vont
faire les régions et qui vaut mieux y
élire tel groupe plutôt que tel autre en
l'occurrence nous parce que nous sommes
le meilleur placement pour les citoyens
mais je sais que ça va
c'est pas bien engagé comme l'a vraiment
je dis aux gens c'est pas la maison quoi
si vous venez tous de dire qu'on combat
les brutes les barbares les terroristes
et tout ça bon bah vous faites vous
utilisez notre arme à nous notre arme
c'est le bulletin de vote c'est la
discussion
le ton peut monter et puis le jour du
vote on n'arrête tous la veille à le
jour du vote on va voter dans le calme
tous on se croise dans les bureaux de
vote on se salue on sait qu'on va pas
voter de la même manière et le soir on
regarde le résultat et on le respecte
donc moi je demande nos gens je veux
dire faites en votre république a way
voté pour la paix civile voilà si vous
voulez voter pour voter ce que vous
voulez mais votez pour la paix civile
donc ne vous était pas besoin national
mais c'est vous qui l'avez dit
[Applaudissements]
alors jean-luc pour finir parlons de
vous car derrière l'image du gars
énerver un peu rigolo qui n'est jamais
content il ya un gars énerver un peu
rigolo qui n'est jamais content ça va
oui j'ai une chanson pour vous dai ça
s'appelle ça m'énerve
[Musique]
voilà c'est une affaire de self et se
retrouve sur terre
m
à mon sens les terrienne bon sens les
terriens nous sommes de retour sur terre
toujours en compagnie de dounia bouzar
jean luc mélenchon ou de guillaume
durand
guillaume durand rebond soit 11
centièmes si vous fait quoi de revenir
sur canal ça ça m'a toujours fait
plaisir sauf un moment un peu ouais
particulier ouais à l'époque vous nous
présentiez nulle part ailleurs vous avez
été viré on peut le dire par les
guignols bruno gaccio en tête au terme
d'une longue campagne de harcèlement
voyez la roue tourne je crois qu'ils
étaient en train de réfléchir à ce qui
pouvait être là près de côté ce qui est
devenu denisot moi je suis passé au
milieu de cette réflexion j'ai pris deux
ou trois balles dans la tête je suis
parti on est passé à autre chose et
voilà est ce que vous pourriez définir
l'esprit canal
je pense que quand ça a commencé avec
andré rousset c'était la révolution à la
télévision ouais maintenant la
différence est beaucoup moins marquée
entre est-ce que crise qu l'esprit canal
finalement c'est pas ses billes en tant
qu poels
donc je suis en couple avec dounia
depuis trois ans
alors il faut dire quand même guillaume
vous avez souffert d'une image de
dilettante comme vous avez dit aimer
l'art contemporain les gens pensaient
que vous étiez beau être fric et que
vous n'aviez pas besoin de travailler
finalement c'est un peu vrai le fait des
fils de marchand de tableaux et en est
ce que valent les oeuvres d'art
aujourd'hui alors que noël père qui
heureusement vit toujours là jamais
gagné avant de sa vie ça fait bizarre
web ou dit j'aurais dû faire comme
michel drucker qui dit qu'il monte le
ventoux et qu'il aime sa grand mère non
mais et c c'est notre maître à tous en
matière de communiquer des politiques
parce que c'est presque de la
communication politique alors c'est vrai
que vous avez une image de dilettante un
peu de mecs qui bossent pas qu'antoine
de caunes a annoncé cet été vouloir
faire une émission intitulée antoine
s'en fiche une émission dans laquelle il
aurait rien su de ses invités tout le
monde lui a fait remarquer que c'est une
idée à vous
ouais mais je veux le revendique aussi
n'ont pas et ne rien faire mais de ne
pas avoir comme vous des fiches parce
que pour montrer à la télévision vous
travaillez il faut montrer quelque chose
si vous bavarder avec jean luc mélenchon
si vous le faites sans fil ça apparaît
comme une conversation c'est vrai m
tandis que si vous regardez melanson
dans les yeux et vous lui dites jean-luc
vous regardez la fiche le le 9 septembre
le 10 octobre 1992 donc vous la lisez
bien la fiche vous avez voté oui au
traité de maastricht en 2005 j'avais
voté contre et c'est là vous êtes
travail
cinq minutes avant je vois monde a gelé
déclaré quand on fait partie de la
petite poignée d'animateurs grand public
la concurrence devient très violente
personnellement je l' ai très mal vécu
en fait je m'étais aventuré dans un star
system qui ne me correspondait pas c'est
vrai
et d'ailleurs je me souviens avoir lu
une phrase de vous qui me paraît assez
juste à un moment que j'avais dit c'est
très difficile pour quelqu'un qui vient
d'un milieu bourgeois de s'imposer dans
un art populaire bien sûr et je pense
que c'est vrai mais on est toujours
coincé entre cette légèreté qui est
celle du music hall des années 30
marlene dietrich et le poids de
l'histoire qui est terrifiant et c'est
vrai que faire le grand écart ce qui a
pu tous nous arriver moi le premier ça
devient très compliqué à comprendre pour
les gens alors vite aujourd'hui
j'apparais de façon beaucoup plus
discrète et c'est plus agréable vous
êtes mis en retrait du star system mais
parce que ça correspond fondamentalement
à ce qu'il me ressemble plus points
alors j'ai pris du recul effectivement
par rapport au mainstream de la
télévision et le magazine télé loisirs
publie un article intitulé que devient
le journaliste guillaume durand ça vous
inquiète pas et ça inquiète y personnes
télé loisirs ouais
vous regrettez pas à l'époque on parlait
de vous faire la une des magazines
manutan pas une seconde vous venez ça
[Musique]
ça c'était générique la secte du journal
de la scène que vous présentiez
regrettez pas cette époque pas du tout
ça a fait beaucoup progresser la
formation à la télévision ce qu'on
appelle maintenant pompeusement de
breaking news une chaîne d'information
il fallait que ça arrive en france et
puis maintenant on connaît à la fois la
nécessité tout ça et en même temps la
distance qu'il faut prendre avec tout ça
parce que quelquefois c'est
terriblement anxiogène et moi j'ai un
côté ashkénazes anxieux même si je
m'appelle durant
alors c'est vrai que vous êtes peu
amènes avec la télévision vous dites
aujourd'hui la télé pas vrai ça fabrique
du buzz pour youtube les superstars de
la culture ont disparu de la télévision
tout et c'est vrai qu'on voit enfin voit
rarement modiano le clézio c'est vrai
non mais c'est vrai mais c'est une 16
quand je dis ça c'est pas de la
réflexion c'est une évidence ils sont 13
comment voulez vous qu'ils aillent se
faire massacrer dans des choses moi j'ai
écrit trois mots sur les dix roses dans
le livre que j'admire énormément fixe
qu'un pire j'ai télévision mais parce
que là on est en étant une émission
formé chez lui rue des marronniers donc
derrière la maison de la radio
effectivement il s'est retourné vers moi
et m'a dit écoutez si on peut éviter de
parler du structuralisme en dix minutes
ça m'arrangerait dans les rangs et la
deuxième chose qui m'a dit mais vous
savez pour ce qui est de la primitivité
du primitif la télévision êtes vraiment
les champions
alors je ne comprends pas pourquoi tes
loisirs se demande ce que vous êtes
devenu vous animer la matinale de
guillaume durand sur radio classique de
7h30 à 9h du lundi au jeudi un segment
de cette émission l'invité politique de
guillaume durand et diffusée sur lci sur
radio classique
quand les invités politiques joue du
pipeau ça vous dérange moins évidemment
c'est l'esprit de la chaîne
dites-moi quand marine le pen vient sur
radio classique mon métier du wagner
non mais il est arrivé que ce soit c'est
comment peut-on dire un pub nas alors
guillaume vous êtes ici ce soit pour un
livre intitulé mémoires d'un arythmique
publié chez grasset alors le pitch vous
vous raconter à travers les rencontres
marquantes de votre carrière vous nous
parlez de vos traumatisme cette fameuse
histoire du marin ivre à belle île en
mer vous avez une dizaine d'années il
agresse votre père avec un couteau et il
poursuit votre père en criant non mais
alors quoi
[Applaudissements]
c'est con
ça vous a traumatisé la faire moi j'ai
vu un type comme dans psychose
d'hitchcock il est arrivé devant moi
j'étais un gosse il veut me tuer je me
précipite vers mon père qui était en
train de lire dans une ferme et eux je
dis papa il ya un type qui veut me tuer
lui ne m'a pas cru évidemment et il a
pris à ma place le type dans le buffet
il est resté paralysé un an ça continue
à me les aurait dans un état quand même
toute façon vous parlez dans votre
bouquin de travail tu mets cardiaque
dont vous à une faiblesse cardiaque
rassurez vous personne va vous en dire
trop de biens ou trop de mal
alors vous raconter les symptômes mais
c'est vrai avec mes cardiaque justement
il ya un jour vous prenez une capsules
de nespresso vous trompez vous prenez
pas du des cas ils la voilà à vous dit
c'est pas possible vous fait opérer
laisse mon médecin avait une france
génial quand il m a dit tu es de
l'arythmie il m'a dit de toute façon
c'est pas grave je dis chouette mais
c'est dangereux merde civile et pour la
moitié de des gens vous connaissez vous
êtes un hypocondriaque dingo et pour
l'autre moitié vous êtes un grain vient
condamner ouais donc il faut trouver son
chemin là dedans et le fait d'écrire est
une bonne thérapie vous avez pris
beaucoup de bêtabloquants de choses
comme ça pas trop fait attention albé
tableau tout le désir sexuel de bêta
tall man mais c'est vrai totalement sais
rien pas que ça dans le livre dont vous
raconter le débat mitterrand ce gars que
vous arbitrez à la sorbonne grand moment
évidemment le climax de votre vie et
pendant les pauses pub une unité mobile
chargé de région le président je ne
servais pas du tout une personne n'ose
aller non mais moi pas du tout j'ai
jamais su je l'appelais après
il faut dire les choses vraiment moi
j'avais une affection pour mitterrand
c'est le dernier président qui est
rentré dans une pièce avec leurs esprits
des gens autour de lui y compris ceux
qui le détestaient ouais d'ailleurs jean
luc l'a connue
mais depuis on attend voilà c'est un
livre extrêmement sincère merci beaucoup
presque trop sincère c'est bien écrit
alors y'a un truc gags qu'on apprend
dans ce livre en fait c'est que comme
dalida guillaume durand et le frère
d'orlando regarder
on passe maintenant de ces la semaine
avec désintox et c'est geoffroy le jeune
de la l'heure actuelle que nous
retrouverons sur ce plateau après le
magnéto désintox de ce soir la lutte
contre des ch
[Musique]
les attentats du 13 novembre ont mis
tout le monde d'accord la france est en
guerre c'est ce qu'a dit notre président
la guerre c'est ce qu'a répété son
premier ministre nous sommes en guerre
et comme sarkozy n'avait rien à dire de
plus d'un il a rajouté un appel il faut
la faire totalement bref nous sommes en
2015 et tout le monde est d'accord avec
ce que disait charles pasqua il y à
presque 30 ans entre les terroristes et
nous et bières la guerre est engagée
pasqua voulait terroriser les
terroristes
trente ans plus tard on voit le résultat
[Applaudissements]
pourtant tout le monde a l'air de
prouver que c'est une bonne idée de se
lancer dans une guerre contre hadès
[Musique]
ah la la le problème c'est qu'en france
on a toujours eu entre 10 et 20 ans de
retard sur ce qui se faisait aux states
en l'occurrence on a 14 ans de retard
sur le discours de bush au congrès après
l'attentât du world trade center en
vigueur
stop
handfield
résultat après avoir détruit totalement
l'irak pour se venger d'une septembre
nos amis les américains se sont rendus
compte que ben laden se planquer
finalement au pakistan il qu'on finit
par le but et obama en a profité pour
faire une belle photo sauf que pendant
ce temps la dèche s'installait en irak
et en syrie aujourd'hui les états unis
et la russie bombarde des choses sans
relâche
mais comment faire pour lutter contre
les djihadistes qui vivent en europe
faut-il aussi les bombarder au lieu de
bombarder jaca la france devrait
bombardé molenbeek jaca on syrie
molenbeek en belgique d'où sont venus
les commandos du vendredi 13 depuis les
attentats tous les discours se
durcissent hollande s'est rallié à ce
que proposait sarkozy en 2012 déchoir de
leur nationalité française les
binationaux condamnés pour terrorisme
nous devons pouvoir déchoir de sa
nationalité française
un individu condamné pour un acte
terroriste mais l'opposition réclame
déjà plus et laurent wauquiez voudrait
qu'on enferme toutes les personnes
soupçonnées d'islamisme déchéance de
nationalité pour les binationaux mais
aussi et c'est le centre du problème
centres de rétention pour ceux qui sont
nés français sans prendre aujourd'hui le
risque d'attendre mais est ce que c'est
vraiment une bonne idée d'en fermer
ensemble tout ce qu'on soupçonne de
djihadisme pas sûr en irak les
américains avaient enfermé tous les
djihadistes en prison pour mieux les
contrôler résultat c'est dans les
prisons américaines en irak que s'est
créé l'organisation de l'état islamique
voilà c'était désintox signé blaco mise
en image de julien grappes qui était au
bataclan vendredi soir et qui s'en est
sorti je vois le jeune bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
notre rédacteur en chef politique à
valeurs actuelles
bienvenue parmi nous dounia bouzar vous
êtes anthropologue et directrice du
centre de prévention
contre les dérives sectaires liées à
l'islam vous avez publié des âmes ans et
l'islam radical comment sortir de
l'emprise djihadiste et la vie après
dash alors vous expliquer en fait une
chose très étonnante c'est que le défaut
d'intégration ou les perspectives
professionnelles ne sont pas forcément
les causes de l'enrôlement dans le
djihadisme on a des enfants de
professeurs des enfants d'avocats des
enfants médecins 3 % des filles
enfin un rôle dans le jihad sont issus
de familles juives c'est très étonnant
c'est ce qu'on appelle la mutation du
discours jihadistes c'est à dire que
pendant dix ans était toujours la même
raison pour combattre ça s'adressait
plutôt à des jeunes que on appelle son
père ni repère fragiles socialement
fragiles familialement et puis là depuis
deux ans on voit que des jeunes comme ça
épanouie premier de la classe peuvent
s'arrêter peuvent se faire embrigader et
la question c'est pourquoi alors vous
expliquer les argumentaires des
recruteurs de dèche alors d'abord il ya
le mythe de mère teresa ça c'est pour
les filles on leur dit vous avez sauvé
des enfants qui sont gazés par bachar al
assad sont des filles qui voulaient
faire infirmières médecins assistantes
sociales qui déjà été altruiste et dans
des familles humaniste et finalement les
rabatteurs arrive à retourner ses
valeurs humanistes contre elle voilà or
pour les garçons c'est le mythe de
lancelot dites vous alors ils veulent
devenir des saunas se battre contre
bachar al assad
et c'est leur raison finalement de
s'engager oui le énormément de garçons
ont pas supporté le fait que finalement
on interviennent pas quand bachar
el-assad et gaz et son peuple l'année
dernière et finalement les rabatteurs et
said leur tenait ce rôle en disant tu
peux pas rester à ne rien faire à être
qu'inutile il faut au moins en fait à
les remplacer l'intervention
internationale voilà alors vous dites
c'est une secte
totalitaire qui ressemble au nazisme et
c'est vrai que pour les nazis tous ceux
qui ne pensaient pas comme eux étaient
des choses et finalement quand ils nous
tirent dessus ils nous vivent pas comme
des personnes mais comme des choses ça
c'est la fin de l'embrigadement c'est à
dire la dernière étape de
l'embrigadement
c'est effectivement de passer de l'envi
de sauver le monde à l'idée que tous
ceux qui sont pas à leur place tous ceux
qui ne pensent pas comme eux tous ceux
qui sont pas engagés dans ce groupe là
sont des gens qui sont complices avec la
dégénération de l'ensemble des sociétés
et du coup ils passent de l' envie de
sauver à l'idée que s'ils veulent sauver
il faut exterminer tous ceux qui sont
pas engagés avec eux y compris les
autres musulmans il faut bien insister
c'est pas une guerre de civilisation
les premiers à être mort c'est les
musulmans syriens qui sont les pauvres
sont parqués dans des tentes et les
riches sont arrivés mais il ne faut pas
oublier que tous ceux qui ne font pas
allégeance sont exterminés alors vous
guillaume non je voulais demander à
dounia c'est parce qu'il ya deux trois
jours dans le monde y avait un grand
article sur est ce que tout ça est une
pathologie ou pas de l'islam ce que veut
des chaussées que l'ensemble de la
planète pensent que c'est une guerre de
civilisation
est ce que veut d'âge c'est que tout le
monde pense que eux ils détiennent la
vérité sur l'islam la part dont j'ai pu
dire un mot juste pour l'intérêt ce que
je trouve de fascinant ce que vous dites
c'est que on revient les pieds sur terre
on voit se construire l'abrutissement
c'est donc pas quelque chose qui a été
donné en même temps que le texte
autrement dit il suffit pas d'être en
contact avec l'islam pour devenir un
dingue alors vous travaillez sur la
prévention et sur le désir brièvement il
ya quand même 700 familles qui ont fait
appel à vous entre janvier 2014 et
octobre 2015 ça montre l'ampleur du
drame jeudi à 1 on suit 700 jeunes
700 jeunes qui tous ont pratiquement été
pris à la frontière menotté qui ont des
fois essayé de partir deux fois trois
fois quatre fois à l'âge de 13 ou 14 ans
et certains rares qui se sont échappés
et qu'ils sont pas en détention et pour
le moment je touche du bois ils sont
stabilisés au sens où un ils sont pas
passés à l'action en france 2 ils ont
arrêté de vouloir partir et 3 ils
essayent de sortir de cette idéologie
alors vous intéresser beaucoup aux
filles c'est le plus étonnant
effectivement brède annan donc elle est
parti là-bas et la survivante à douala
mais quand on quand elles arrivent en
forme dans le mât car c'est quoi le maca
quand les filles arrivent en série en
fait elles sont pas le droit de de
marché si elles ne sont pas mariés donc
elles sont fermées dans une énorme
maison fermée et on apprend tellement
pas de matelas chacune qu'elles n'ont
pas d'eau pas de nourriture pas de
corans non plus d'ailleurs au passage
elle n'en sortirons qu'à condition
qu'elle puisse se marier avec celui qui
va venir les demandeurs et donc elles
vont accepter de se marier avec des
inconnus fend d'une douche pour manger
quelque chose et donc annan est la seule
rescapée vivante qui a pu s'échapper de
dèche ll n'y allez pas du tout pour
combattre elle pensait que c'était un
monde dur et un vrai amour une vraie
solidarité des vrais soeur pas
d'injustice pas de voleur c'était ça
c'était ce que j'appelle d'iceland elle
en sourit maintenant elle dit maintenant
elle en sourit mais vous dites quand
même qu'elle a une certaine nostalgie et
qu'elle ressent de la culpabilité
ne pas avoir été une bonne musulmane
nous le dit quand même c'est bien le
rappeler ça parce que j'ai écrit le
livre ya deux mois et c'est vrai qu'il
ya deux mois est là elle se disait qu
est ce qu est ce que comme une femme
battue est ce que finalement j'ai pas
été à la hauteur pour pas voir que
finalement c'était pas super un super
projet 1 mais maintenant vous voyez deux
mois plus tard c'est terminé vous êtes
un travail remarquable c'est gentil
[Applaudissements]
bon alors jean-luc mélenchon
pendant longtemps la gauche a refusé de
s'attaquer au problème de la
radicalisation pour pas paraître
islamophobe je conteste le terme
d'islamophobie quoique je le comprenne
je comprends ce qu'on veut dire ce sont
les musulmans qui pensent qu'on leur en
veut parce qu'ils sont musulmans donc je
comprends l'homme mais moi je défends
l'idée qu' on a le droit de ne pas aimer
l'islam on a le droit de ne pas aimer la
religion catholique et que ça fait
partie de nos libertés et par conséquent
je n'ai jamais accepté ce terme même si
je le comprends et que je partage l'idée
qu'aujourd'hui les musulmans sont mis
dans le sale rôle comme il y a une
génération c'était les juifs et que des
milliers de gens souffrent en silence
parce qu'ils n'ont rien à voir avec tout
ça geoffroy le jeu mais il ya un truc
qui me dérange dans vos deux discours
c'est que vous faites en sorte l'un et
l'autre d'expliquer qu'il n'ya aucun
rapport dans les attentats avec l'islam
or vais passer complètement à côté selon
moi du problème numéro un aujourd'hui
qui se posent à nous en france pas à
l'étranger en france c'est qu'est ce
qu'on va faire avec les musulmans demain
en france il ya aujourd'hui un islamisme
un islam radical qui se développe à
vitesse grand v dans notre pays dans des
endroits on sait très bien lesquels
d'ailleurs dans les banlieues notamment
et que tous ces gens qu'on va faire des
attentats aujourd'hui sont des gens qui
ont qui se sont formés dans des mosquées
dans des caves etc et ne pas le dire ne
pas dire que ça a un rapport avec
l'islam ça fait qu'on ferme à fermer les
yeux comme on l'a fait après charlie et
on ne réglera pas le problème il ya
juste un souci dans votre raisonnement
c'est que qu'est-ce que vous faites du
fait que 50% des jeunes qui sont
embrigadés n'ont rien à voir avec
l'islam n'ont jamais connu d'immigration
mais ce sont des gens de famille athée
ou catholique premièrement je pense à
nous en parler par les très jeunes qui
sont signalés non pas des jeunes qui
sont embrigadés non et je ne reviens
brigade et qui sont parties aux deux
autres à la frontière ça fait donc
parler des jeunes dont dont vous avez
reçu les reçu des signalements ça n'a
rien à voir avec les jeunes absolument
pas il ya 4000 parents qui ont signalé
leurs enfants d'accord c'est ce dont
vous parlez ils sont quatre mille sont
pas 700 les 700 que j'ai moi c'est des
jeunes qui ont été menottés à la
frontière qu'on a récupéré ou bien qui
se sont enfuis d'âge c'est pas des gens
signalé c'est des gens embrigader c'est
d'exercer des gens qui devaient passer à
l'acte je vous parle de cela
ces 700 là j'ai 60 % qui sont de famille
athée qui sont juifs et qui sont cathos
discussion s'il n'a que 3 % c'est encore
pu donc comment comment expliquez vous
que des gens qui ne connaissent pas
l'islam d'accord qui n'est pas eu
d'instruction que les 30% de référence
musulmane ce soit toutes les familles
qui ne pratiquent pas l'islam les
familles qui connaissent l'islam elles
sont protégés de da et vous savez
pourquoi parce que nous on sait ce que
c'est l'islam donc on vous croit ni vous
ni d'âge parce que vous et dash vous
avez la même définition de l'islam vous
pensez que c'est une religion par
essence arcade qui par essence va faire
couper des têtes nous nous savons que ce
n'est pas le produit de notre religion
bien on continue donc avec la lutte
contre dahesh il ya le terrain d'abord
22 pays participent à la coalition mais
95% des bombardements sont réalisés
enfin jusqu'à dernièrement par les
américains la france va lancer quelques
bombinettes de temps en temps les russes
taper sur les ennemis de bachar al assad
aujourd'hui est ce qu'on peut penser
arriver un seul front bas c'est en train
de se faire puisque finalement hollande
va rencontrer poutine et que pour
l'instant il semble qu'il ait une
coordination des bombardements qui
n'existait pas il ya trois jours il ya
un moment où face à la catastrophe qui
est en train d'avancer
les les stratégies régionales qui était
fondamentalement différentes sont en
train de se coaliser pour c'est ce que
jean luc mélenchon appelle l'heureuse
volte face de françois hollande elle est
heureuse mais elle est extrêmement
tardive non moi je vais vous dire un
truc dans cette émission ça fait trois
ans qu'on dit qu'il faut arrêter de
considérer poutine comme un ennemi et
que s'il faut s'associer avec bachar al
assad pour flinguer daage tant pis on
sait bien associer avec staline pour
flinguer clair les trois ans qu'on dise
ça veut dire que ça fait trois ans que
poutine a raison sur tout et françois
hollande a tort on est en train de
donner raison au type qui était présente
et je crois que je crois qu hillary
clinton l'avait trahi il avait comparé à
un nazi quasiment bruit et aujourd'hui
on entend dire la satire pas raison
depuis le début c'est comme moi j'ai
reçu des mails j'ai reçu des coups de
téléphone en me disant arrête de
soutenir poutine je ne soutenait pas pou
ti mais bien sûr je voulais juste qu'on
s'associer avec lui les russes sont
nécessairement nos partenaires voilà il
faut que chaque français comprennent ça
mais jean-luc depuis sarkozy qui a
rejoint l'otan nous sommes devenus les
parfaits caniche des américains mais
parce qu'il ya un point de vue
complètement idiot logique de ceux qui
dirigent aujourd'hui le parti socialiste
était d'une manière tout à fait ces
nouveaux drames c'est quoi cette
idéologie qui nous interdit de nous
allier avec poutine contre d'âge qui
nous interdit de reconnaître que bachar
al assad est pour le moment pour le
moment un allié qui nous interdit de
signer la paix avec l'iran alors que
même les américains font la paix avec
l'iran et on a tout intérêt à tromper
avec l'iran qu'est-ce que comment vous
appelez cette idéologie qui est défendu
par hollande valls effet on apprend au
premier niveau c'est à dire ce que c'est
concrètement concrètement ces de
l'atlantisme ces gens considèrent que ce
que les américains trouvent bon est bon
pour tout le mois la voilà ensuite vous
avez un deuxième niveau c'est que y
compris par rapport à ce que racontent
les nord-américains et choisissent
dedans et ils sont plus proche des
néoconservateurs qui sont des
va-t-en-guerre que des démocrates qui
sont plus plus modérée geoffroy en fait
j'étais d'accord je suis assez d'accord
avec lui mais où lancée lui qui est
d'accord avec moi je sais pas il ya un
truc par contre sur l'idéologie qui est
encore pire on en a parlé c'est par
rapport à la série puisque c'est quand
même que cette semaine bernard squarcini
l'ancien patron des renseignements
révèle qu' il ya deux ans la cire il
repose et de lui donner les noms des des
jihadistes français qui étaient allés en
syrie et que manuel valls à l'époque
ministre de l'intérieur a refusé de la
voir parce que ça voulait dire coopérer
avec les scieries ce qui vous avez
raison pour des motifs idéologiques est
interdit à l'heure où aujourd'hui on se
remet à travailler avec la syrie pour
manuel valls c'est juste c'est
gravissime comme comme acte alors on
continue avec les lois sécuritaires
alors jean-luc moi je vous dis tout de
suite et assez tranquillement je ne suis
pas convaincu par la proclamation de
l'état d'urgence sur trois mois je ne
vois pas ce que ça apporte de plus
l'intervention en salle samedi a été
réglée par des moyens ordinaires ce qui
est partiellement faux puisque c'est pas
pour être désagréable mais ceux ci se
sont affranchis de toute décision de
justice puisque même les maires le maire
de saint-denis personne n'a été prévenu
non à la veille à 4h30 du matin donc
c'est une chose qui a été décidé par la
direction générale de la police qui a
envoyé le rêve et la berri sans prévenir
personne donc on est dans un état
d'urgence de fait qu'il faut pour normal
à ce que d'aucun état d'urgence prolongé
à trois mois c'est plus un état
d'urgence et un état commun et vous
créez un revers de la main il quitte le
jeu vous vous arrêtez l'état d'urgence
va vous envoyer un signal qui est
extrêmement négative bien alors
assignation à résidence bonne idée
mauvaise idée monique bonne idée mais
mais ça pourrait aller beaucoup plus
loin moi je trouve que l'idée de laurent
wauquiez de les interner faire de la
rétention adminstrative ces gens là sont
dangereux sont une menace pour notre
sécurité il faut les ne demandiez savez
vous il faut les juger d'abord mais non
le problème c'est que c'est justement si
on fait la guerre on fait pas la guerre
c'est si on fait la guerre à ces gens là
à moi ils menacent mais sécurité je
préfère les savoir retarder si on me dit
je connais un criminel qui va jeter une
bombe voulez-vous l'interview je vous
réponds oui mais deux secondes après
monsieur dit ah bon il est interné tous
il y en a quatre mille donc vous savez
comme moi que si on a interdit celle-ci
personnes où ça s'appelle un corps où on
leur met un bracelet et il faut avoir le
personnel pour surveiller tout le monde
que nous n'avons pas hésité on n'a pas
les moyens qu'elles en ont tiré ce qu'on
attendait mais thierry commençons par
tirer les leçons avant de passer encore
comme d'habitude vite vite concrètement
en huit mois en deux secondes comment
nous allons régler la guerre mondiale
thierry comment en est on arrivé là une
suite d'erreurs qu'il faut corriger il
faut restaurer l'état dans sa force en
france il faut restaurer le géopolitique
qui tiennent debout il faut donc arrêter
la guerre là où elle part comme je le
dis et le répète ça ça peut être réglée
en même pas deux mois dounia il ya
quelque chose de très simple
qu'apparemment vaud s'est pas pris en
compte c'est que les 4000 personnes qui
sont signalés sur les 4000 personnes
c'est 3800 parents qui ont téléphoné à
la police pour dire mon enfant est en
train de se faire embrigader
si ils nous écoutent aujourd'hui je peux
vous assurer d'une chose il ya plus un
seul parent qui va signaler que son
enfant est embrigadé par ce que vous
avez dit on va tous les internés
d'emblée dès qu'ils sont signalés mais
alors là maintenant vous êtes en train
de tout casser le système de prévention
que le gouvernement a mis en place
depuis deux ans et c'est pour ça que les
gens appellent et c'est pour ça qu'à
4000 personnes qui sont fassiez monsieur
dernière question faut-il fermer les
mosquées intégristes et expulser les
prédicateurs salafistes parce qu'en
angleterre par exemple il on expulse e10
par semaine et quand un prédicateur fait
un prêche dans une mosquée il doit la
faire accepter par une autorité
musulmane locale en france les mecs
raconte n'importe quoi où ils veulent
est-ce qu'il faut fermer les mosquées
intégristes à ma connaissance ce
nettoyage il a déjà été fait un bond oui
à ma connaissance en tout cas tous les
musulmans savent qui a toujours eu des
micros dans les mosquées tous les
musulmans savent que le radicalisme
autour des mosquées parce que justement
il se méfie énormément de la police
française et à ma connaissance il ya
très peu de jeunes qui se font
embrigader à l'intérieur de la mosquée
et au contraire ils font bien attention
d'aller à l'extérieur ça c'est ma
connaissance l'uniat je voulais ce que
le mot de la fin
die jeudi nous gagnerons parce que nous
aimons la mort plus que vous n'aimez la
vie et le mot de la fin c'est que il
faut pas tomber dans leur piège l'islam
c'est pas la mort l'islam même la fin du
monde dont l'islam c'est symbolisé par
un arbre qui renaît alors ne tombons pas
dans leur piège et donnons-nous la main
pour dire que la vie c'est plus fort que
la mort
voilà jean luc mélenchon maire s'il
aimerait bien avec nous je ferai le
jeune vierge il est vrai que c'était la
b2 de l'excellent t on se retrouve après
nature avec deux amis guillon enoch
terriens du samedi 20 heures ce soit
alain robert le spiderman français
l'homme
[Musique]
bonsoir bonsoir intérieure au rebond sur
les terrains nous sommes de retour
chauffeur toujours en compagnie de
dounia bouzar
guillaume durand et les accueillant
notre terriens du samedi 20 heures ce
soir alain robert
à la robert bonsoir en vingt ans vous
avez escalader 125 gratte-ciel et
monuments à travers le monde vous êtes
le spiderman français on regarde
[Musique]
vous nous raconterez notre histoire à
20h dans salut les terriens
voici stéphane guillon
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bonsoir mes petits terriens depuis
l'horreur des attentats qui ont frappé
la capitale vendredi dernier je n'ai pas
envie de rire encore moins de faire rire
même si certains disent qu'il ne faut
pas courber la tête que le show must go
on même si je ne vais pas pleurer à
grosses larmes comme laurence ferrari
sortir une boîte de kleenex comme
madonna ou me jeter dans une salle vide
comme shy'm
difficile de contenir son émotion
malheureusement ces dernières années
beaucoup de drames nous on est anisé le
11 septembre les tueries de mohamed
merah les attentats de charlie hebdo et
l'assassinât de perles la chatte de
marine le pen
nous traversons une période de deuil
chaque mot prend une résonance
particulière
ainsi samedi dernier france 2 a eu
raison de déprogrammer de fiesta avec
patrick sébastien
chanter quand il pète il trouve son slip
vingt-quatre heures après un tel drame
c'est délicat pour les mêmes raisons
salut les terriens a été déprogrammée
afin de laisser la place à maitena
biraben comme si une catastrophe ne
suffisait pas je plaisante je plaisante
difficile de trouver le ton juste
on se réveille avec la gueule de bois
complètement plombé sans jeu de mots on
n'y croit pas 129 morts en plein paris
129 je précise comme david pujadas on a
annoncé 140 dans le feu de l'action et
puis j'adore c'est un passionné c'est
lui qui avait dit ouah génial quand un
avion avait percuté le world trade
center faut le comprendre à ce genre
d'événement ces trois semaines de boulot
assuré autant les humoristes nous avons
les jambes coupées sans jeu de mots
autant les journalistes y sont en pleine
bourre depuis dix jours ils ne dorment
plus ne se nourrissent plus mobilisation
générale tous les retraités de l'info
les réservistes ont été rappelés jean
claude bourret henri sannier marie laure
augry tous sauf bruno masure comme il a
écrit un livre ou une insulte ses
anciens camarades plus personne ne fait
appel à lui vingt-quatre heures d'infos
sur 24 sans la moindre pause depuis le
13 novembre le record de nagui au
téléthon a été pulvérisé avec la plupart
du temps rien à dire ça qui est fort je
vous interromps david avec une très
belle image celle de cet enfant qui a
décidé d'offrir son doudou une peluche
hello kitty à la mémoire des victimes
mais aussi bernard riverains du bataclan
qui a joué quand les hommes vivront
d'amour à la clarinette même s'il
manquait des notes très très beau moment
d'émotion merci bruce n'hésitez pas à
nous appeler en cas de nouvelles
urgences
24 heures d'infos sur 24 c'est crevant
on tombe parfois dans le non sens des
phrases qui ne veulent rien dire j'ai
été surpris en plein réveil ou bien des
morts en état d'urgence absolue
inévitablement tous les autres sujets
d'infos passe à la trappe le
déraillement du tgb en alsace dix morts
tout le monde s'en est à p&g l'on
m'annonce qu'il y aurait dix morts dans
le déraillement d'un tgv merci dominique
mais bruce nous rappelle du bataclan où
la peluche hello kitty seraient une
peluche doha une information à prendre
avec beaucoup beaucoup de prudence
et en août des trucs fatalement david
pujadas à choisir il aurait préféré que
le tgv alsacien des rails dans un mois
et merde merde pendant quinze jours on
m'a rien hélas deux trucs super qui se
télescopent merde
personnellement il ya un sujet qui m'a
beaucoup intrigué et qui a été très peu
traité c'est le mystère de ces deux
kamikazes du stade de france qui se sont
fait sauter sans faire de victime les
actionnent leurs ceintures alors qu'ils
sont tous seuls tant mieux pour nous
mais faut vraiment être con
attention un kamikaze situe merde tu
peux pas recommencer c'est définitif
cresci doivent être curieux hfr
l'investissement la formation les
billets d'avion non même si pour
kamikaze qui prend un aller simple c'est
quand même de l'argent
du coup je sais pas s'ils ont le droit
aux 72 vierges promises au mart et parce
que si tu rates ton coup tu as le droit
aux vierges si ça se trouve c'est ça qui
les a déconcentrés les 72 vierges de
toute l'année une boîte que des femmes
en burqa et là on leur promet des
vierges et sont tellement envie d'y
aller il actionne le truc trop tôt
c'est ce qu'on appelle l'éjaculation
précoce du kamikaze
[Applaudissements]
oui les femmes martyres on leur propose
de retrouver leurs maris au paradis
c'est pour ça que ma très peu qui rend
barbu analphabètes qui te tape dessus
tout la journée le retrouver au paradis
comme récompense il ya mieux
j'aimerais achevée sans jeu de mots
j'aimerais je fais cette chronique avec
une pensée pour mahomet je ne le connais
pas personnellement mais j'aimerais lui
exprimer ma sympathie je sais qu'il
entend des voix peut-être entendra-t-il
la mienne
ça doit être dur pour lui avoir une
partie de ses fans aussi demeurait tir
d'ech c'est un neurone pour 1000
combattants à ce propos pourraient avoir
été une bonne fois pour toutes d'appeler
le cerveau le décérébrés qui a organisé
tout s'est tu auras
à la semaine prochaine winch à la brave
[Applaudissements]
prochain ici la socan et walter et ont
tourné
on passe maintenant à notre terriens du
samedi 20 heures
[Musique]
alors on un rebond choir
vous êtes né le 7
1962 à digoin en saône et loire votre
père était un ancien sergent chef de
l'armée de l'air à oran devenu
commercial dans les télécoms en
métropole à son arrivée votre mère était
secrétaire en algérie et en france elle
est devenue femme au foyer la famille
s'installe à valence dans la drôme et
alors bizarrement enfants c'est vraiment
un trouillard la nuit vous vous rêvez
que vous tombez sans fin dans un gouffre
noir et vos cris vous réveille c'est
peut-être aussi ce qui m'a donné envie
de faire complètement à l'opposé de
partir justement sur les chemins
verticaux c'est fou et enfin vous aviez
peur du vide j'étais complètement à
paralyser tétanisés alors le deuxième
problème quand vous êtes enfant si vous
ne mangez rien évidemment votre
développement physiologique en prend un
coup et partout où vous allez vous êtes
le petit quoi voici toujours pas très
grave alors troisième problème l'école
vous êtes gaucher et vous écrivez de
droite à gauche ça c'est encore plus
encore plus rare pour rééduquer en vous
attache la main gauche dans le dos et là
vous devenez parfaitement ambidextre qui
sera utile pour la suite c'est évident
c'est très pratique voilà et puis un
dimanche après-midi vous regardez un
film américain tiré du roman d'henri
troyat la neige en deuil c'est
l'histoire de deux frères qui
entreprennent une expédition en haute
montagne vers l'épave d'un avion
l'aîné veut retrouver des rescapés
l'autre veut détrousser les cadavres et
ce film vous ouvrent les yeux sur la
montagne disons que moi quand j'étais
môme je pensais au départ je voulais
faire quelque chose un petit peu dans
l'esprit de zorro robin des bois alors
que la grimpée des montagnes ça semblait
davantage à portée de main vers l'âge de
10 ans vous est envoyé en colonie de
vacances
évidemment avec le groupe des plus
petits et là vous décidez de vous
échapper vers le haut ça commence vous
avez vous asseoir sur le toit et vous
regarder tout ça très calmement donc
très jeune vous prenez de la hauteur
j'avais quand même envie de me prouver à
moi même que je pouvais faire quelque
chose avec avec ma vie avec la verticale
alors au retour de la colo votre père a
été victime d'un infarctus du myocarde
votre mère est à son chevet à l'hôpital
et là vous devez vous débrouiller tout
seul et un jour vous partez au collège
en oubliant les clés alors on retour
évidemment vous décidé d'escalader la
façade sept étages j'étais un petit peu
dans l'urgence dans l'obligation et puis
je me suis dit allez tu y vas je me suis
lancée puis qui charrie des envies au
sommet plus jamais je me suis dit tu
seras incapable de grimper alors à 15
ans vous grimpez les falaises du vercors
fait 400 mètres quand même en solo
intégral sans la moindre sécurité vous
dites je préfère l'indépendance à
l'assurance je me sentais en sécurité
de tenir des aspérités plus ou moins
grosses et puis finalement ne plus
réellement avoir confiance au matériel
alors le premier accident fait du fait
du ski hors piste vous tombez sur une
plaque de glace à l'hôpital les toubibs
vous révèle que vous êtes épileptique et
le mecredi glabre l'escaladent pouvait
dire adieu 1 c'est fini bon goût c'est
ça ce n'était pas une très bonne
nouvelle loi que je sais pas exactement
ce que c'était l'épilepsie mais bon ça
allait s'éteindre avec mais rien ne vous
arrête en 1982 vous décidé de grimper la
mythique falaise ardéchoise l'abominable
homme des doigts en solo intégral donc
c'est à dire son corps d'un ce n'est pas
un sport vous dites c'est une ascèse une
1 c'est ce qui m'est devenue vitale
ouais c'est devenu je vais faire je me
suis tellement battu veut dire de delage
de du petit gamin que j'étais qui avait
peur de tout qui avait peur du vide et
finalement à de me retrouver là c'est
devenu un mode de vie c'est c'est toute
ma vie en fait vous fait une chute de 20
mètres vous tombé tête première sur une
dalle rocheuses le bilan c'est une
semaine de coma la peau déchirer les
veines tranchées les eaux du bassin des
jeunes ou des coudes des poignets en
miettes et le toubib bouillie dans votre
cas on ne tente pas de fracture mais de
fracas au ce quand même la première
chose qui m'est venue à l'esprit
si je veux demander
quand est-ce que ce pourraient regrimper
effectivement quelques semaines plus
tard vous signez une décharge pour
quitter l'hôpital et rentrer chez vous
avez décidé de reprendre l'escaladent
alors vous installer une barre de
traction dans le chambre hall d'une
porte et bientôt vous fait 700 traction
en une heure et en deux ans vous devenez
une sorte de surhomme mais avec trois
doigts hors d'usagé quand la main cet
exo pose d'une du nerf cubital a
sectionné votre corps est devenu si
puissant que vous arrivez à faire des
tractions avec un seul doigt
[Musique]
oh
alors là dessus vous avez des
étourdissements vous allez voir un oral
qui vous dit votre accident vous a
détruit l'oreille interne et vous allez
avoir de violents vertige toute votre
vie j'ai trouvé une antidote à un mantra
le montre assez de répéter sans cesse
j'ai confiance en moi et je réussis tout
ce que j'entreprends j'ai confiance en
moi et je réussis tout ce que
j'entreprends j'ai confiance en moi et
je réussis tout ce que j'entreprends
apparemment ça marche ça a l'air de
marcher en
1986 donc vous escaladez l'abominable
homme des doigts d'amitié tomber en solo
intégral et en 94 vous escaladé la tour
citigroup à chicago
187 m alors première difficulté monte le
plus rapidement possible pendant les 60
premiers mètres parce que 60 mètres
c'est la hauteur maximum d'une échelle
de pompiers donc une fois que vous êtes
au dessus de 60 mètres ils peuvent plus
vous rattraper il m'avait dit pour les
pompiers leur faut à peu près deux
minutes ouais t'as deux minutes pour
être là 60 m deuxième difficulté la
surface vitrée parce que là c'est pas de
la roche il n'y a pas de vérité ça
glisse vous accrocher ou les cadres
qu'il ya autour des vitres parfois et
des fissures
parfois il n'ya pas y'a pas grand chose
il ya juste des petites aspérités des
petites réglages et on se faisait déjà
arrivé quand vous montez un moment de
plus rien donné pour vous accrocher non
parce qu'en fait j'ai fait des repérages
au préalable j'utilise les jumelles ou
alors je vais dans des bâtiments voisins
à un side observé correctement course
mais là vous découvrez une autre havre
enalean une fois que vous êtes en haut
vous découvrez la jungle d'acier de
verre avec les gratte ciel qui
jaillissent comme ça il ya un terrain de
jeux potentiels à qui s'offrent et en
fait on retrouve partout lexique osmani
en passant par les états unis ou la
chine entre 1994 et 2000 15 vous
escaladez 125 gratte-ciel et monuments
dans le monde guinness book évidemment
parmi elles le golden gate à san
francisco 200 m 7 m l'obélisque de la
concorde la tour montparnasse 209 m le
taipei one one taipei la tour ariane 152
mètres la tour first à la défense
231 m et la plus haute le burj khalifa à
dubaï
828 ce qui est drôle c'est que quand les
filles vous vous arrête vous retrouver
en taule et là en fait vous ce nobel et
les autres prisonniers parce que vous
faites
quarante pompe sur un bras dans tous les
cas ils sont évidemment très admiratif
et on vous appelle vittel charti les
muscles c'est pas j'ai pas la taille
mais mais ça fonctionne alors quand on
vous parle de la peur vous dites oui
effectivement j'ai peur mais je tire mon
plaisir de dominer cette peur de faire
abstraction de la chute c'est ça votre
force en fait ce que je fais c'est avant
tout mental après je mets mon corps au
service de messagerie finalement j'ai
peur comme tout le monde mais je peux
mettre ma peur de côté c'est la grande
différence avec nous
alors c'est extraordinaire
c'est que la sécurité sociale vous
considère comme invalide à 66% mais
évidemment pour toucher cette pension
d'invalidité
il faut être sans activité et être sans
activité c'est impossible pour spider
man c'est totalement impossible donc
j'ai toujours préféré ne pas avoir
d'argent allouée par le gouvernement
français et vivre de ma passion
[Musique]
voilà c'était salut les terriens votre
troupe du samedi avec dounia bouzar jean
luc mélenchon guillaume durand chose 3
le jeune est à l'envers merci de
témoignages je vous signale la sortie du
rire notre collaborateur et ami jacques
sanchez les bonnes chansons ne meurent
jamais c'est humilier chez flammarion
c'est toute l'histoire est marié à la
télé
ils m'ont aidé à faire cette émission
salut
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu